used to go around like universities and
stuff and pretend I was a lost student
and black people for many
um yeah I used to make quite a lot of
money doing that at the time I was on a
90 mil methadone script and I was using
two two to three hundred pounds worth of
heroin and crack a day
[Music]
I had a great childhood uh
everything I could ask for really
um
you know growing up on a
on the outskirts of Cardiff you know
um had friends you probably didn't have
their mother around or their father
around you know
um single parents
but um my family great household uh
they're still together to this day and
we had everything we wanted really
um in the summer we play sports
um they made sure I was involved in
every activity anything I asked for if
they couldn't get it they'd get the next
best thing and
yeah I got fun memories as a child
when did you start going down a
direction when did you start taking
drugs
um I started taking uh
drugs at like the age of 16 17 I
remember in high school I was really
against drugs I was anti-drug my uncle
was a heroin addict he was in prison for
a long time and uh
I remember my father my mother my
grandmother I used to see him go through
a lot of stress we used to go prison
visits and stuff so I always kind of was
dreamed into me the drugs were bad
my dad was anti-drug never smoked the
[__] never you know would drink on the
weekends but you know non-mirchen
um I don't know it it kind of I was in
coming into my last years of High School
uh really where
I started to venture out on taking drugs
started with cannabis
um and a lot of people would say this
isn't true but it was a gateway drug for
me I had a few problems uh with myself I
had my mental I had a severe mental
health uh issues
and I put my
um Pathway to drug drug addiction into
into three ways and I was bad timing the
the people I hung around with
and my mental health
I was diagnosed with severe OCD and ADHD
but what people
I think when you say OCD is you know
you're a clean freak you know and that's
clearly not the case for me
um if you went to my bedroom we're in my
house you wouldn't think I had OCD but
um it's more of a ritualistic thing uh
and I used to get obsessed with certain
things and I always used to have like
these anxious paranoid thoughts
um and if I'd have to do these certain
rituals and these rituals could you know
differentiate day to day
um
and if I didn't do these rituals then uh
I automatically uh think something bad
would happen either to myself or to a
loved one you know when we're all young
like we we the pressure of of growing up
being in the crowd and stuff we don't
want to admit we've got problems we
don't want to open up that we've got
problems so instead of saying I've got
problems uh you know I would
try and find ways to mask it and and
Drug uses
that was what the drug use was for
and how old were you when you first took
heron
um I was seven uh
just turning 18 when I first tried
heroin
um I was 19
full-on
quote unquote smack head
can you talk us through the sort of the
hold it can have on you
just just runs your life you you you're
a prisoner to it you you can't do
nothing
um
you know all I I you know and for the
first couple of years I tried to uh
blend in try to cover it but
you might think you've got it under
control but you just clearly haven't
um you know you can't go down the pub
you can't go on the weekend with the
boys because you have to slow off
because you need to use or you know it
just takes all your normal social events
away from you and uh that's just a
little that's you know that's just
talking about the effect of what it has
do normal things
uh the abnormal things I were doing to
get the drug was was horrific
um and the first five years of addiction
I used to go around like universities
and stuff and pretend I was a lost
student and black people for many
um yeah I used to make quite a lot of
money doing that
um and then it was only towards the
second half of my addiction
um when I started to become uh a
shoplifter and again up and down the
country shoplifting
um but it was just pure desperation the
whole time sheer desperation
and how many times have you imprisoned
10 11 times 10 I know I've been every
time I went to prison I did try to
change my way it was it was a time for
me where I thought I needed to change
and every time I was in prison
I always looked at like you know I'm
going to get up this time and sort my
life out every single time and there was
a few times I'd have to go in there and
do a detox do a cluck off the heroin
um but uh there was times as well that I
was on a methadone script whilst in
there um and that don't help anywhere in
the methadone script to me is
um it's kind of just dumbing you down as
a person I would say I've been on
probably
15 20 methadone Scripts
kicked off started again where it's just
a
a vicious circle type of thing so um
yeah every time I come out of prison I
was you know back to using
how did you stop
um so obviously lockdown was was
different it was it was new for all of
us but especially for someone like
myself who's a shoplifter a lot of the
retail stores were shut so um we were
traveling around to hit like a small
Cooperative shops and uh it was just
getting on top it was really it was I
was really manic at the time this was
like probably the worst I was
was a different person
um and I knew my body was was
deteriorating at the time I was on a 90
mil methadone script and I was using two
two to three hundred pounds worth of
heroin and crack a day I never injected
heroin I always smoked it so I always
had a problem with my lungs while I was
smoking so much
and um uh one day in it was uh September
the end of September coming up to August
we've just passed two years and um
basically a friend of mine passed away
who was my co-defendant he used to drive
me around everywhere and he passed away
and the same day he passed away I got
rushed to hospital
um and when I when I went into hospital
I I come around a day later
with all needles in me and stuff you
know drips and stuff in both arms and
they said I had a sepsis and pneumonia
um and I thought I was gonna die like
you know I've many many times before
like I've
I've been in bad situations where I've
had to do detoxes and you know I've been
in hospital beds prison beds done all
the stuff what I thought we'd you know
this is the last time but I genuinely
knew this was the last time um so
whatever my friend and I were using it
it obviously had an effect on us when I
was in hospital I kind of had this like
Awakening sounds cheesy I know
um but I I had this type of Awakening
and I knew this would have to be the
time I had to change I couldn't go
through another
another another detox and so what was
different about either
your treatment or your mindset for the
time that you that you got clean last
um
this is probably the the best thing
that's ever happened to me
um and I think it's an amazing thing as
something called boo Vidal it's a new
drug
basically that's being tested uh here in
the UK especially in Wales
um I actually it's funny I actually
heard about the drug uh whilst I was
still
um coming up to where I almost went into
hospital I heard about this drug that
was going to be getting rolled out
during lockdown for um chaotic uh users
like myself but then when I went to
hospital
um and I was you know really ill in
hospital the nurse come to me and he
said look we'll keep you on your
methadone script but you're gonna have
to go every single day now uh include uh
including weekends
um or go try this boo Vidal and um it
was the best thing that ever happened to
me you know I'm I'm two years clean now
the first time in my adult life I'm I'm
free of drugs so how does Beaver doubt
work so it's it's an injection uh in in
into the muscle
um you can have it on in your buttocks
your arm I has it in my stomach because
I've I've got a bit of a value there so
um and what it does is it basically
um releases a blocker into your system
which lasts for 30 days so with
methadone and with subutex and other
opiate substitutes they last 24 hours
you need a new dose and there's a lot of
bad effects with these these drugs as
well with methadone you can still use on
top because it's an opiate also with
methadone
um it ruins your body there's this this
myth that like you know uh it gets
inside your bones uh it feels like that
um also it makes you actually feel like
you're still using drugs because it
gives it's very strong so if you are
trying to get clean and they put you on
a methadone script you're just going to
feel like you're ahead of an attic still
this is that that famous word for
Methadone they call it the liquid
handcuffs where
um you know you're a prisoner to it this
bouvadol
um straight away it helps a lot of
people uh in the sense of getting their
life back not only that a lot of these
places where you go to pick up your
methadone
um is full of other people who are on
drugs uh a high percentage of them don't
really want to come off drugs they're
using methadone as another way of a high
so um my dad used to say is uh these
places where you pick up your methadone
it's like going to a gamble is Anonymous
in the in the coral or an AAA meeting
within the weatherspoons
for those that are on like yourself Boo
the dial if you did decide to go up go
out and get heroin again would it what
effect would it have yeah it would do
nothing like
you might as well uh
you might as well just get a lighter
than just be in your money literally
like it's it's it does nothing the
difference with blue Vidal other than
the methadone and Subutex you don't get
a buzz on it it's not like a methadone
where you kind of feel a bit this this
is a total block it like you feel
totally normal again and that can be
tough for people who have suppressed
their mind with such a strong painkiller
for so long a lot of people in addiction
are hiding from trauma or they're hiding
from things they've done whilst on drugs
so it's masking problems and when you
know you take that that blanket off
people struggle what was that first
month on it like for you yeah it wasn't
easy I'm gonna be fair
um like I said when I
it was the first month my my friend just
died and
I've got all these emotions coming back
as someone who's coming off heroin as
well
um which you do anyway you know um
my uh I'm having wet dreams you know I'm
feeling like the life's going too quick
for me I'm thinking about everyone I've
robbed I'm thinking about everyone I've
heard in my life uh
I'm thinking about my meat passing
trying to put blame on myself like it
went it went
it wasn't comfortable for me so I can
imagine other people who go on it it
might not be the most comfortable but
when you get past our first month it's
amazing it's literally I I live a normal
life now
how long did you use for in total uh
well it was coming up to 13 years 12
years
um if you include this one I first tried
it at 17. do you ever think what what it
was about you that put you down that
path
yeah like it's
you know um
I always say like um I've been I said
something recently
about how like we try and dig for trauma
like when when you go to see like a
doctor or something they'll tell you to
like tackle the root problem and because
like I was never a you know I had a good
childhood I was never abused as a kid
it's not like you know
um someone in my family you know was
like a tragic death and I could never
find out what the problem was
um and that's kind of why I carried on
using because I didn't really find out
until
towards the end when I started you know
coming off the drugs that I realized
that like it could be the littlest of
things that make you
um take drugs and and have mental health
issues and stuff
so um when I look back it was definitely
my mental health and the decisions I
made as a young child whether it was a
small thing or a big thing I now work
for
um
a company called Kaleidoscope uh who
were based in Newport I'm now employed
within my city of Cardiff with a project
called voices action change and it's all
about co-production service user
involvement you know it was only two
years ago I was actually on them streets
running ragged so a lot of them know who
I am they've seen me at my worst they
know
I'm trustworthy and uh we're just trying
to
change
um the way we run services and have more
of an involvement from people within
Services there's just a massive stigma
around
drug users drug addiction
Junkies
uh
that's what needs to change
I woke up once and my world was never
ever the same
and that's when I realized that I was
physically
and mentally addicted to it